we live in a generation now where you
get a trophy for just showing up you are
where you are because of the actions
that you are taking it's pretty easy
sometimes to to feel beaten when you're
faced with all those issues and all
those problems and they all hit you at
the same time rise and shine it's
expresso time good morning believe
nation it's evan my one word is believe
and i believe in you i believe you have
an amazing gift inside you that i want
to see exploded onto the world so grab
your coffee and sip on today's message
don't try do over to you eric thomas
[Music]
sometimes me doing my research to find
out how do I help the millennial
generation right I was watching one of
my homeboys speak right he's phenomenal
I was born in about the wrong way I've
been to my execution in March if I've
been on that execution is worship you
got to execute
you got to execute we're speaking two
different languages what he shared with
me is this is the generation of trying
like in your generation you get brownie
points for trying so what you do is you
do selfies that ain't real and so I
didn't get it y'all get actual credit
but trying to look like you got it
together like some kind of way when you
take a selfie even though you've done
absolutely nothing you literally do a
selfie and you get crazy you get street
cred for that like you get you yeah well
you wouldn't be doing it and so you put
on your makeup and you get into place
and then you make it like you do it
eight times and then you get the right
one and you put it up and you drop a
filter on it and you get credit for that
see the reason why I've been so hard on
y'all is because where I come from and I
used to watch the people on my block go
to Ford GM and Chrysler they wouldn't
get credit for selfie didn't get credit
today checked in and they was on the
line once and then they did it for 40
hours didn't they get a check they
weren't blessed to get credit for trying
I'm sorry it ain't so far we live in a
generation now where you get a trophy
for just showing up it's not
you play on the football team y'all
didn't win one game but you get a trophy
a deer you get a job you know we don't
want hurt your feelings are you hear
what I'm saying
I want to rewire you the problem that
you're having is that you're looking for
rewards when you just show up and you
think of somebody should be grateful
that you showed up I want to show you I
want to show you a Bruce Lee's say a
long time a book so you don't take
offense to it no one is not enough we
must apply execute okay he didn't say no
one is not enough you must try it's not
what he said he was probably one of the
best that ever do what he did willing is
not enough we must do you do not I
cannot try to pay my mortgage I cannot
try to help my wife quit her job I
cannot try to pay my kids go to school I
can't go to Michigan State and say I
want to try to pay tuition this money
they're gonna say okay we won't try to
teach your kids gonna try to put him in
the dorm
gonna try there with me knowing again
knowing come on knowing we must apply
willing is not enough we must we must
every single day if you do what you said
you're gonna do you're gonna get what
you dream to get you deserve to have
everything you receive I think this is
one of the healthiest attitudes that you
can ever take in life and in business is
that you are where you are because of
you because of your actions because of
your mindset because of your beliefs you
have the money in your bank account
because of you because of what you have
done it's not your mom's fault it's not
the president's fault it's not the
school system's fault it's your fault
and it's a great attitude to have
because you can change it because you
can't change your mom and you can't
change the school system at least in a
short amount of time but you can change
what you do you can change your beliefs
you can change your output you are where
you are because of the actions that you
are taking and so I look at my YouTube
channels an example and people write in
to say Evan you deserve to have 10
million subscribers and that's so
flattering it's so amazing I really
appreciate you guys but the reality is I
don't I don't deserve to have 10 million
subscribers the content I'm putting out
is not good enough my team is not good
enough yet the output is not good enough
yet the Siri
your crane is not good enough yet me
personally ultimately it's all my fault
I am not good enough yet in front of the
camera behind the camera picking the
clips everything we're not good enough
we don't deserve to have 10 million
subscribers but I also don't deserve to
have zero I don't suck my team doesn't
suck we're awesome we're not good enough
to be a 10 million we don't deserve that
but we do deserve to be at 1 million you
put in a lot of work he's been a lot of
effort a lot of energy a lot of love so
we don't deserve to have zero and I
think people play that game I think
people are locked between the I'm i zero
or I'm a hero right and nothing in
between and so you need to recognize
that you're always on your path so on my
path to 10 million I'm gonna stop by one
then we're gonna get the two and we're
get the three four or five right all the
way up so really healthy exercise that I
recommend you do is look in the mirror
and ask yourself why am I not more
successful why have I not accomplish the
goal whatever goal that you have for
yourself
for the end of this year or next year or
five years or ten years or whatever
those goals are that you have for
yourself why have you not accomplished
it yet and the only reasonable answer
that should be coming back is something
related to you stop blaming the economy
and the dollar and the currency and
Bitcoin and governments and everything
else none of that matters
does it have an impact sure but you
can't control that you can control you
you can control your actions and you
could change it when you accept the
responsibility to change it so look
yourself in the mirror and ask yourself
why you have not accomplished your big
goals yet and when you look at it from a
perspective it's all my fault and use
that as a kick forward not down not that
you suck and you never will be great at
anything it's all my fault and I can get
better
and I could change it and I can improve
it when I start doing more when you
adopt that mindset that everything is
your fault and you are in complete
control to be able to change it going
forward that's when you start to win now
I've got some special bonus clips for
you but before getting to that my
question of the day for you is what are
you going to do more of right now today
in your life in your business to make
meaningful progress on one of your big
goals what are you going to do today
leave it
the comments below I'm really curious to
find out thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you I hope we
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever you're one where it is much
love enjoy the bonus clips and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning for another
shot event spresso
[Music]
my assistants got a great thing now and
this once in every four months somebody
sends an email saying I've got a huge
startup that I want you to invest in but
you've got to sign this NDA right which
literally every time gets an email back
that says you write and and the reason
is I'm a humongous believer that ideas
are and that executions the game right
we've all got ideas everybody's got
ideas doing ideas we all have here we
could probably sit here for the next two
hours draw them all out record them and
predict the next 78 great startups over
the next nine years and so I think the
thing that is another theme in
entrepreneurship is there is way too
much fodder brought to the idea Bluebird
was magic cab three years earlier
uber is not an idea who ever existed
it's called magic cab but the guys that
executed sucked so they lost so I think
you know if there's any level of romance
left in this room about your idea I'd
like to suffocate it because I think the
actual situation is what you actually do
with it when things go wrong they always
seem to happen at once and they just
compound on top of each other and it's
it's pretty easy sometimes to to feel
beaten when you're faced with all those
issues and all those problems and they
all hit you at the same time but let me
tell you that that doesn't mean give up
in fact it means the opposite it means
it's time for you to fight harder to dig
in means it's time for you to go on the
warpath and that starts with one of the
fundamental laws of combat leadership
prioritize and execute what's the
biggest problem
well what's causing the most stress
family okay
sit them down explain where you are at
the blunts be up front and then give
them the simple plan of how you're gonna
get things back on track don't sugarcoat
it you give it to him straight next
you've got some some late payments call
those creditors up explain to them
what's going on set up some kind of a
low of a minimum payment plan so you can
start making some progress and get them
off your back and then you got your job
right you're falling behind at work okay
talk to your boss
face it tell him that you're gonna step
up your game tell him you're gonna be at
work early you're gonna be at work late
you're gonna be at work during lunch
you're gonna be wherever you need to be
whenever he needs you to be there tell
him you're gonna get after it and tell
them that you're a hundred percent
committed to supporting him and the
company and the mission and then you get
started if you have to think of one word
that's most important to you or that
sums you up or that would be like a
little beacon hey believe nation if you
want to know what the most important one
word is for Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and Howard
Schultz I have a very special secret
video for you check the description for
details
you